♫ (casual background music) ♫
(sigh)
I don't know what to play today.
(drinks out of cup)
Everyday I got to find a new game, it's so hard.
How could I possibly find a game,
that is GREATER,
than any game that I have ever played before!
It won't happen.
(chain breaks)
(PewDiePie in background): What is this?
♫ (typical anime title theme music) ♫
(spits out water)
Oh!
OH!
Oh! Are you SERIOUS!?
THE GRAVITY!
THE GRAVITY GOES UP!
It came from her boobs!
Finally!
Thank you, YouTube gods!
(on loudspeaker) WE DID IT! WE FOUND THE BEST GAME EVER!
OH! OH!
(police sirens)
Oh my god!
OH MY GOD!
OH my god!
I'm crying...
DON'T. TELL. MARZIA!
Whatever you do, DO NOT TELL MARZIA!
The fuck is this?
How do I skip?
(pressing buttons repeatedly)
Get meh to the titties!
(continues pressing buttons repeatedly)
(clicks mouse repeatedly)
Oh my god, they always drag out the thing!
Oh my god!
Look at the gra- oh my god!
It's-it's one of those videos, guys.
It's-um... (drinks a shot of alcohol)
Oh my god!
They... whatever!
Alright, alright, I'm 26!
OH MY GOD! I CAN-I CAN BEAT THE SHIT OUT OF THEM!
JESUS!
Why am I kicking the shit out of these women?
Could this be the greatest game?
The music!
The gameplay!
The boobies bouncing!
Listen, you're watching the video!
Stop JUDGING me! Alright?
What's going on here?
Oh- ooh!
OH!
(takes another shot)
Argh!
What's happening?
WHOA!
WHAT JUST HAPPENED?
Oh!
Thank you, Jesus!
Can you stop?
Eh- I mean, keep going!
PFBT!
WHOO!
WHAOW!
YAAA!
BEST GAME!
SHE'S TRANSFORMING!
AMAZING!
WHO!
Whoever plays this for the game-play is clearly lying.
I can't lose now!
I'm nak- my controller's not working!
MY CONTROLLER'S NOT WORKING!
GODDAMN YOU XBOX!
I will NEVER forgive this!
Hey!
Maybe it's not so bad after all...
YOU GOING DOWN!
OOH!
OH!
I think there's a story going on,
but I haven't really understand any of it.
It's a good game.
It's got a good soundtrack.
It's got-s'got good game-play.
It's got good music.
I have-it's got good, good story.
I-
I am playing it for all of those reasons.
Man, this A.I. in the game is so good.
Look how clever they are.
Listen, what you need to do is go close to the wall,
then you gotta turn around, and then go-
GODDAMNIT! I'M TRYING TO LOOK AT MY TITTIES HERE!
Oh my god, I can see my own panties!
This is better than Yandere Simulator!
OH MY GOD, IT'S PANTIES!
Oh my god!
(continues to drink more shots)
Oh no! She's transforming!
What are we shall transforming to?
Oh my god!
THEY POP OUT!
As everyone knows,
the less armor you wear, the more armor you have!
What the FUCK is this?
WHAT THE FUCK WAS THAT!?
OH.
MY.
FUCKING.
GOD!
How can this game be so good?
I DON'T EVEN KNOW HOW I ACTIVATED THAT SHIT!
God, I NEED to know how.
How did I do that?
What a fucking welcome.
Jesus Christ.
"Rainbow Panties"
Yes please, I will take this, and this, and this, and this.
(gunshots)
OH MY GOD!
Rainbow Panties!
AAAHHHH!
"Merry Chirstmas"
Merry Chirstman, indeed.
Secret ninja attack!
What's she gonna do?
What is she doing?
She became huge!
OH MY GOD! SHE'S ATTACKING WITH HER ASS!
Oh my god!, She has no tits!
Oh my god, this is child porn!
What the fuck am I doing?
What the fuck is happening?
Oh no!
I don't wanna see her transform,
it's weird, this is weird.
She's like 8, what the fuck?
No thanks!
OK, that's adorable.
What am I still playing this game? The video was done LONG ago.
Jesus Christ.
And, she's dead.
This attack is my favorite attack.
The ass attack is the best attack this town has ever known.
I can't- my controller doesn't work!
MY CONTROLLER DOESN'T WORK!
GODDAMN YOU XBOX!
NO!
Doesn't work!
How could this happen?
No! (crying)
Goddamnit!
Ah, ahhhhh! (continues to cry)
I can't live!
I CAN'T LIVE, BUT I'M JUST KIDDING!
WHY?
WHY, Senpai-chann? *Very sad pewds*
(drinks a shot while sobbing)
(Boy)How much money do you have?
(crying continues) *So sad*
(music fades) *Feel better soon pewds :)*